When we talked about quadratic inequalities, it referred to things called
critical numbers. These are the numbers that divided up our number line into the
different intervals that we could consider to figure out which ranges of values
satisfied our inequalities. For quadratic inequalities, we got these numbers
from factoring and depending on what rational expressions we have that maybe the
case as well. But we can generalize about it. You remember that for quadratic
inequalities, we found our critical values by figuring out which values of x
would cause the quadratic expression to equal 0. And we basically have the same
requirement for rational inequalities except that this time, we have one
polynomial divided by another polynomial. So, you have two different sources of
critical numbers. In either case, whether we're talking about the numerator or
the denominator, we'll come up with a critical value for every value of x that
will make either one of those 0. Considering this method for finding critical
numbers, what critical numbers do you find for this inequality that we were just
talking about? If you happen to find more than one critical number, then please
separate them by commas.